the world's biggest sporting event
that's the World Cup is kicked off in
Qatar and despite facing multiple
controversies there was a lavish opening
ceremony yesterday complete with a
ginormous fireworks display take a look
at that in the Opening match host nation
cutter lost to Ecuador the U.S teams is
hoping to have much better luck today
they're playing against whales Roxanna
sabiri is there and has more on the
story Roxanna good morning to you
good morning Gail This World Cup has
already proven to be one of the most
controversial in history because of the
location the Heat and concerns over
human rights here but the hosts hope
that now people focus on the festivities
and the soccer
coach put me in I'm ready to play with a
pep talk from President Biden the U.S
team one of the youngest at the World
Cup is gearing up for its first match at
age 28 goalkeeper Matt Turner is
considered an elder it's going to be
very challenging but I think you know
for a young team it's a it's a good
opportunity to test ourselves against
some Elite teams how would you
characterize this U.S team they're very
inexperienced on the global stage
together this is journalist Grant Wall's
13th World Cup there's a lot of
variability in how they might perform
because of their youth the tournament
caps over a decade of controversy over
Cutter's treatment of Migrant workers
who built the stadiums and its laws
criminalizing same-sex relations
this weekend the president of FIFA
soccer's World governing body Unleashed
a nearly one-hour defense of Doha so
what do you want to do about it
you want to stay home and Hammer and
criticize
and say how bad they are
the visitors are starting to pour in for
the party and with cutter deciding only
Friday to ban beer from the stadiums
multi-million dollar sponsor Budweiser
is banking online that official fan
zones like this instead I know there's a
lot of political things and a lot of
other things that are going on I think
that every country there's no country
that's perfect American fans here tell
us they're focused on their team a group
that Defender Walker Zimmerman sees as
diverse yet United it's a fun group it's
a competitive group I think you can find
at least one person on this team that
you can relate to it's kind of what
makes America so great
concerns over human rights here and
invited migrant workers to a training
session in Doha and it's displaying a
rainbow Crest at its fan parties in
support of lgbtq Rights the team plays
its first match against Wales today Nate
all eyes will be on that U.S versus
Wales game all right Roxanna Siberian
cutter thank you